had one panic attack in my life and I
read this on you like that you suffer
from panic attacks and anxiety right I
had one when I was pregnant with my
little girl and I was driving and I
couldn't move like I was like oh my god
am I about to die and I was literally
look at my hands like and I couldn't
breathe it was like shallow breathing
I'd never experienced that and it was my
first pregnancy that that happened with
my little girl and I read but you suffer
from anxiety and panic attacks you I do
and how do you deal with that I have had
them my whole life it's so interesting
for me and this obviously is probably
with you too but I don't get them when
I'm performing like I feel most at home
when I'm on stage like I don't have any
anxiety about that but I get them just
in my day to day life and you know my
life changed overnight with two Broke
Girls I you know went from being a nanny
and a bartender full-time and then was
on national television and a lot of
pressure as you know with four wheeler
and you stay on your horse okay anyway
so I I started to notice that my anxiety
got worse not while I was performing
just off-camera red carpets I don't do
well with anything like that and so
horrible you're the worst people don't
know but it's yeah I smile to make
myself laugh so I'm like and they're
yelling at you yeah yeah it's like like
you know you know and and actually
Whitney Cummings who's co-creator of two
Broke Girls and I said to her you know
when are my character on the on the show
had a horse living in New York City
named chestnut and when the horse was on
the show I noticed that I was calmer
more grounded at rehearsal I was so
happy I mean always loved animals but
there was something about the horse and
I mentioned it to Whitney and when he
was like I have a friend her name's
Sandra Ogier she's this incredible
acquaint era pissed oh yeah you don't
have to ride you won't do anything it's
all on the ground
it's super spiritual go work with her
and she completely changed my life
because horses are prey animals so they
only live in the present moment you know
they can smell if a mountain lion is far
away so in order to work with them which
you know but if you're not a horse
person people don't understand this but
they will only respond to your authentic
behavior in that moment so if you're
scared but you're trying to show that
you're not scared they're gonna be like
boy bye like because they said they
sense it yeah and so something I found
really empowering which do I believe in
a coin therapy is that when you realize
this huge animal that could kill you
responds when you're just your pure
authentic self whether you're happy sad
angry whatever it is that day you get to
show up as you are and that's enough and
they're gonna want to respond and
communicate because they're feeling your
authentic truth and I thought that that
was one of the most empowering things
and it really helped me get over my
panic attacks that's cool I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this